what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so continuing our ketchup videos
with DC rebirth we switch over to
unstoppable from Aquaman and this is
actually a really really cool story I'll
be honest with you guys for all the
Aquaman fans like rebirth is winning me
over it's funny because I covered a
Aquaman rebirth the deluge I think it
was the first story arc and then I
hadn't covered it since it hadn't really
read it too much since but like getting
back into this man it's winning me over
hardcore like it's it's really really
good and that's what everybody's been
telling me they're like dude Aquaman in
DC rebirth is exceedingly good so but
the cool thing about this is that this
picks up with a couple different things
you remember when it came to the new 52
where previously Mara was always kind of
believed to be the wife of Aquaman when
DC rebooted they basically brought her
from Zebulon so that she was originally
an assassin task of killing Aquaman then
basically fell in love and the two had
kind of been together ever since the
result is that she's not really highborn
of Atlantis
she's Harborne of Zeebo meaning that
she's of royal blood but because she
doesn't hail from Atlantis she's not
really attuned to Atlantis's customs
things like that now this was one of the
common traits that was shared between
Meera and Arthur curry in the sense that
Arthur curry was born you know and in
really in like amnesty Bay and he spent
a bulk of his life on the surface so he
was never really raised with the
traditions and the beliefs of of
Atlantis the difference here is that in
a lot of ways he gets a pass because
he's the rightful king and so which is
kind of like what it is whatever I want
to do and while a lot of people do a
grudging Lee at the end of the day they
don't really have the authority to
overrule the king and not many members
of Atlantis are going to go with them
now that's really where groups like the
deluge kind of step in where it's just
kind of like okay look we are not a fan
of Aquaman being King and we want to
bring him down so that kind of brings
the other half of that fold into the
equation but for Meera because of the
fact that she's basically the girlfriend
of Arthur curry at the moment in terms
of actually being his wife they're not
really married yet she does not have the
same kind of rights or authority or Thor
curry has and so the result is that we
basically have these more or less like
widowed women is really what they are
they're basically widows of either
husbands or they're the mothers of sons
who have died in battle but they are
some of the longest standing members of
of Atlantis because there's kind of a
tradition here in the sense that when a
soldier gives their life for Atlantis
it's like the highest honor they can
achieve they understand the true nature
of what it means to sacrifice to
Atlantis and in turn they gain a higher
bit of reasoning so they're more like
priestesses or kind of like female
versions of monks and anything else but
the idea behind this is because of the
fact that they're mothers and they're
their wives and things like that they
really begin to kind of bring Mira in
for the purpose of going through the
ritual trials and what these are
designed to do is basically demonstrate
that she is capable of being a queen to
Aquaman now in truth in terms of like
what's going on in the story the role
she's played this is really more of just
like a circumstance than anything else I
mean honestly it's not really a
requirement just because of the fact
that she knows what it means to be
highborn meaning she knows what it means
to be a royal blood and the
responsibilities that come along with it
and because of the the various struggles
that she's faced alongside Arthur curry
she's as much suited to be a queen as
anybody else if not better suited and so
she's really kind of going through the
paces because this group has the ability
to block the marriage from happening and
so it's more or less like fine I'll do
it not because I want to but because I
have to now the other half of this comes
in the form of Black Manta again Black
Manta being one of the most notable
villains of Aquaman had basically taken
over a group called Nemo which existed
for the purpose of controlling the
various you know aquatic resources of
the world and kind of controlling things
behind the scenes but because of the
fact that his vendetta against Aquaman
is really like the first and foremost
thing he goes for what they ended up
doing which is kind of releasing this
incredible being that has kind of shows
up to attack Atlantis now of course as
we get into this the funny thing about
this is notice this being is virtually
unstoppable hence the name of the story
there's really nothing they can do I
mean we have the drift which are
basically like the black ops team of of
Atlantis and I just want to say that's
such an awesome name like it's such an
awesome name to call yourself the drift
like where we're just like where the the
highest like where the elite warriors of
Atlantis and were called adrift that's
such a cool name that name it's just
such a cool name to have but the funny
thing is where they try to take it out
they knock it down occasionally but it
always gets back up it always keeps
making a return not only that it keeps
healing itself now of course Aquaman
being the most formidable fighter of
Atlantis really isn't able to do
anything on his own so the kind of
question you have to ask here is how in
the world could they win now of course
again Jaime back to Mira this is really
one of the more interesting aspects of
the story in truth the whole conflict
with Aquaman is pretty straight forward
I mean it'll it'll develop but you know
some meat potatoes of its own as a story
goes on but it's you know really in the
moment it's really more about Mira than
anything else because one of the things
to keep in mind is that in terms of the
publication history of her character
she's always been headstrong that really
goes into like the evolution of comics
in a lot of different ways and again you
know the kind of sidetrack from the
story for a second you can
trace the evolution of society alongside
the evolution of comics because comics
are designed to mirror society I said
when you look at like women in comics
for example while you know Lois Lane was
kind of like yeah you know I'm
headstrong and I'm a bit fiery at the
end of the day she was the damsel in
distress well Superman will save her
Superman will always save Lois Lee as
the years progressed that began to
change and that's why when you get into
Lois Lane really in like the 1980s 1990s
even in the 70s and somewhat the 60s a
lot of fans love Lois Lane they
absolutely loved the character of Lois
Lane because she's headstrong she can
stand on her own two feet
I mean she's easily someone who can
handle her own now of course even if
only for the sake of storytelling
Superman will show up from time to time
in order to help her out but a lot of
times it's one of those things like I
don't need your help and I don't want
your help and fans love that because it
shows independence and and all that kind
of cool stuff and it really gives a lot
of female readers someone to idolize and
so the result of this is that Meera was
kind of brought in in this era where
comics were starting to transition to
the idea of women kind of stepping into
their own in the comic book landscape
and becoming more significant characters
and so the result is that with Mary's
character Ashleigh exists in the here
and now she's very much reflection of
how she was before DC rebooted in the
new 52 innocents that she's not someone
you want to trifle with and she's not
someone you want to mess with
she's pretty headstrong and pretty fiery
and that really shows itself in her love
for Aquaman of course is basically this
idea that she sees the trials as
nonsense she's like look you cannot
instill in me anything I don't already
have I'm already a warrior because I was
trained to be an assassin
I love Arthur curry because he's the man
that I'm gonna marry we've been through
so many things you guys only really
understand how deep the relationship
goes between the two of us it's
interesting because it's basically
people she doesn't know anything about
who don't really know anything about her
outside of where she comes from who's
never been alongside her and Arthur
curry when they've gone on their various
adventures and when you know Arthur
curry fought Superman and different
things like that they weren't there for
any of that yet somehow they're in a
position to where they can determine
whether or not she's allowed to be
married you guys see where she's coming
from they don't know anything about her
yet they're gonna decide whether she
gets married or not it's a huge pill to
swallow and that's why it works but
again getting into whole the whole
situation with uh with with Aquaman the
funny thing about this is that once we
get into this in terms of them facing
off against this foe what we end up
finding out the monster they're facing
off against is actually shaggy man now
shaggy man is cool the shaggy man is an
absolute
like he's a beast shaggy man appeared
back in 1966 with Justice League of
America issue number 45 and the whole
idea behind shaggy man is that he's kind
of like doomsday before doomsday in the
sense that he heals and he adapts to
whatever it was that injured him in the
first place and that's the cool thing is
because he's always been this absolute
almost unstoppable force when it comes
to the Justice League in the sense that
he can't really be defeated through
conventional means which is to say
beating a mob or shooting him with the
old heat vision or something along those
lines now really when when when it comes
to like shaggy man was when the shaggy
man comes hunting for you it's gonna be
almost impossible to take him out and so
the result is that Aquaman really kind
of makes this case look we can't take
this guy out through conventional means
not only that we end up finding out the
destination of the shaggy man is amnesty
Bay and again this is part of the the
whole intention of Black Manta and this
is what I want to talk about for a
second one of the reasons why a lot of
Aquaman fans really enjoy the villain
Black Manta is because he's not really
your typical villain you know he's much
like Lex Luthor in a sense that it's not
just a physical battle you know Black
Manta doesn't really have like
superpowers like Aquaman but he does
have like enhanced combat ability
different things like that but it's a
war on multiple fronts break Aquaman
psychologically break him mentally break
him down to the point that like he loses
the will to fight or something along
those lines
that's why attacking amnesty Bay is so
important because that's the home of
Aquaman Aquaman's true home is not
Atlantis attack Aquaman's true home so
he can never really go back he could
never really go back to his home again
and he loses that part of himself that's
why it works and that's why it's
intriguing because where they're kind of
chasing after the shaggy man and where
the scenario becomes the shaggy man's
going after amnesty Bay then now it's
not just a matter of amnesty Bay being
attacked
it's the areas around amnesty Bay now
remember this is important because
relationships between the surface world
and Atlantis are tenuous enough as it is
and so where Aquaman is in the midst of
trying to like stem this tide and trying
to you know neutralize the struggles
between the surface and the Atlantean
Society if a being like shaggy man just
kind of explodes from the Seas and then
just starts attacking and Misty Bay and
the government hears about it the
government's gonna think Atlantis is
attacking us again they're gonna
consider it a first strike and all-out
war is gonna it's gonna take place but
the whole idea here is that with the
shaggy man showing up it does kind of
highlight the idea that there are people
who still don't like Aquaman that still
kind of consider him to be more of a
nuisance than anything else
the other
half of this is Aquaman's pride under
normal circumstances he would call in
the Justice League and that's what one
of his guys say why don't you call in
the Justice League now this is something
I want to talk about for a second this
is a big deal because this is the
question a lot of people ask there's a
lot of different surface you know
scenarios and circumstances it exists
out there in comic books where you're
reading about this battle where
superheroes fighting with every ounce of
strength they have and it seems like
they can't win and the question becomes
well why don't they call on the Justice
League or why don't they call on the
Avengers why don't they call on the
other x-men or something on those lines
well in truth one part of that is just
for the sake of storytelling it wouldn't
make for a very interesting story if at
the climax of every single event the
Justice League got called in writers
kind of have to maintain this balance
between you know the superhero fighting
a villain on their own winning against
all odds and coming out on top while
also providing an answer to the fans and
that's the question here why does an
Aquaman call in the Justice League now
again this really kind of fits into the
nature of like Atlantean pride
Atlanteans are like we're the ones that
know what we're doing we don't need help
from the surface world we don't want
those evil surface dwellers here you
know we can handle our own problems and
so for Atlanteans in a lot of ways the
shaggy man attacked Atlantis now listed
Atlantean threat but with this this
scenario the question of the top ranking
member of Aquaman's forces is call in
the Justice League man but you're
talking about a beam is almost
unstoppable that's got incredible
strength he's taken you for the ride of
a lifetime calling the Justice League
for help and Aquaman's response is no
I'm not gonna call this in it's a matter
of pride it's really all this is and
pride comes before the fall and that's
why this is cool is because Aquaman is
not thinking rationally and he's not
thinking reasonably here now ultimately
he does he uses his Justice League card
he calls in the you know Justice League
satellite and basically has a teleport
shaggy man outside of Earth you know
into a space itself now of course this
seems to indicate the idea that maybe
he'll adapt and he'll be able to breathe
it and eventually come back down he'll
arrive or something along those lines
that we don't really know but it is kind
of cool because in response to this we
kind of get this question of with him
collapsing and sort of passing out what
does this mean for like the future of
Aquaman with regards to the Justice
League if he refused to call them in in
a moment of dire nead is he standing
apart from the Justice League did you
not want to have anything to do with a
team anymore is he effectively quitting
because his cards out there now his
cards floating out there in space and so
we can't access the watchtower anymore I
mean there's no real key for him to be
able to get in there and so that's the
question that this becomes is what does
it stand with regards to his character
without being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end
but if you are new here to come this
explain and make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the Robin
Court you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
you